[Music]
if you want it you will find time in
your life to do it if you don't want it
you will continue to do exactly do it
now give me excuses you're going to make
it every excuse and why you can't do it
and that's why I can't connect it to you
that's why you hear the passion come out
of me and you want to say it's anger no
because I know it can be done and you're
telling me all this [ __ ] on why it can't
be done and then you what you do is he's
crazy he's in the character you don't
want it bad enough if you want it bad
enough you will figure out how to make
this [ __ ] happen
that's David Goggin and this is the
referral podcast
[Music]
the rich roll tadka greetings everybody
happy new year my name is rich roll I'm
your host welcome or welcome back to the
show where I get intimate and go long
form with some of the world's most
intriguing thought leaders high
performers and positive change makers
all across the globe these are
conversations designed to help all of us
unlock and unleash our best muscle tent
excel so thank you for stopping by today
I appreciate you tuning in
I appreciate you subscribing to the show
on iTunes and for sharing it with your
friends and on social media and all that
good stuff and I'm super duper excited
about today's episode I honestly cannot
think of anyone else on planet earth
better suited to help you kick off the
new year right than today's guest David
Goggin is somebody I've wanted to get on
from the very first day that I started
this show mainly because he's had a
tremendous impact on me and my life
personally in many ways it was his
example that inspired me to enter the
world of ultra-endurance and really
quite honestly I'm really not sure that
I would have ever achieved the things
that I've achieved as an athlete had he
not lit the path so let's break it down
for the uninitiated David Goggins is
often referred to as the toughest human
on planet earth here's why first of all
he is the only member of the US Armed
Forces to complete SEAL training US Army
Ranger School and Air Force tactical air
controller training so unbelievable
right so there's that but he is perhaps
best known for his superhuman feats of
strength and ultra endurance and this is
a journey that began after several of
his friends died in Afghanistan in a
2005 helicopter crash David decided that
he wanted to honor their memory by
tackling the 10 most difficult endurance
challenges on the planet and he wanted
to do this as a way of raising funds and
raising awareness for the Special
Operations Warrior Foundation which
gives college scholarships and grants to
the children of fallen special ops
soldiers and hence began quite a storied
athletic career some of the highlights
of David's accomplishments include a
world record in 2000
13 for the most pull-ups in a 24-hour
period he did 4025 pull-ups in 24 hours
he has multiple top finishes at the
badwater 135 which is a 135 mile ultra
marathon across Death Valley widely
considered to be the world's most
difficult foot race he has a third place
finish at the double Ironman distance
Ultraman World Championships which is a
race that I've been privileged to
compete in a couple times and then there
is the 203 point 5 miles that he ran in
the 48 hour National Championship
endurance foot race beating previous
records by 20 miles and earning a spot
among the top 20 ultra marathoners in
the world if that's not impressive
enough he did this shortly before he was
diagnosed with a hole in his heart a
condition that had him competing
basically on only a fraction of his
ability had his heart then properly
functioning so just think about that for
a minute and on top of this he's got
dozens of other ultras under his belt
and a slew of other impressive results
from such daunting events as the
Leadville 100 the hardrock 100 and on
and on and on so these results are of
course incredibly impressive but perhaps
David's greatest accomplishment was that
he had to overcome a battery of almost
insurmountable obstacles faced
throughout his life to become the man he
is today things like asthma sickle-cell
anemia
psychological and physical abuse and
childhood obesity academic struggles and
even this congenital heart defect that I
just mentioned there's so much to
David's story beyond the foregoing it's
just a remarkable and incredibly
inspiring tale if you listened to my
podcast with Jesse it Fleur he's the
author of the book living with the seal
that was RRP 197 then you already have
some familiarity with today's guest
because David Goggins was the seal that
moved in with Jesse to shake his life up
a bit so if you missed that conversation
with Jesse I would definitely go back
and listen to that it's really fun and
engaging but with respect to David
Goggins suffice it to say that I think
he's really one of the most remarkable
people I've ever met
again is somebody who has had a profound
impact on me personally and I can
promise you that you will be profoundly
impacted by this conversation it's a
conversation that will leave you
rethinking your goals reassessing your
priorities questioning your limits and
really pondering your purpose it's a
conversation about the limiting beliefs
we impose upon ourselves that hold us
back it's about the importance of
mindset and ultimately it's about what
it means to be truly alive so welcome to
2017 people I can think of no better
guest to usher in the new year send
David Goggin so without further adieu
ready man let's do this alright so I'm
driving down Sunset Boulevard a couple
days ago
and I don't come into town that much I
was way out in Malibu Canyon so it was
weird for me to be like in this part of
town anyway and my wife and I are going
to this event and she goes check that
dude out who is that guy you know and I
go that's Gauguin I've been doing here
was like the weirdest like juxtaposition
like I just wouldn't like I just
wouldn't put those two things together
like it just seemed weird and I was like
and just reminded me so I sent you and
no because we were trying to hook this
up right well I'm glad it worked out man
yeah thanks for thanks for getting back
to me and before we even there's so many
things I want to talk to you about but
before we even like get into any of it I
just want to say like on the record I'm
sure you don't know this but but you are
you have been like integral in my story
behind the scenes like I read about you
and bad water and Ultraman back in you
know it must have been early 2007 right
and that's really what inspired me to
begin training for Ultraman and I've
gone on and competed in that race and a
couple of times wow that's amazing and
that experience changed my life you know
change it changed everything about how I
live and what I do Wow
and the initial spark was really reading
I think it was competitor magazine the
article not just about like the hundred
mile er that you needed to put in to
qualify for bad water kind of like threw
in bad water on broken feed and then and
then like three months later do an
Ultraman on like a borrowed bike that
you had to tape your feet to the pedals
and I was like who is this dude and the
fact that you had never been a
triathlete or when I was like as I was
coming off of being a fifty pound
overweight like couch potato dude and I
was like look what this guy did that's
amazing like if he could do that like
let me reach a little bit right in 2008
I did my first Ultraman did at 2009 2011
going on to do some other things
congratulation Titan yeah what I mean
thank you for thank you for shining a
light you know what I mean and it's an
honor and it's privilege to finally get
a chance to sit down and talk to you I
appreciate that goal and I saw we met
briefly at badwater 2013 I was crewing
for Dean okay and we
I don't know if you how much you
remember like it was cat mouse with you
was a FERC Hawkins we're talking yet
remember was crone for you and we were
not in the same vicinity for a large
part of that right here and that was a
horrible turn you didn't look like
you're having fun was I was really sick
yeah but good to go cool so what brings
you to Los Angeles you know what I
retired from the military and just
different meetings with different
companies as far as like possible TV
shows who was in who's this crazy nut
guy John Hollywood you know what not too
hard that's who you are
so just see what happens on your right
how's it so some projects in the mix and
development or just meeting with people
in general about the idea of it or just
meeting the people I'm nervous about the
idea of you know who I am and what I
could possibly bring to whatever's going
on I hear right so was that a reason why
it was it was strange because out of the
blue you went from being like you know
really private deal and suddenly you're
just all over social media sharing
videos and alright Instagram like it
just ramped up from like 0 to 60 which
is your style of call right but like was
that part of the calculus like okay I'm
not in the military anymore like I got
to find a way to like sort of spread my
message now you know I'm actually glad
you said that I'm a I lived like a monk
and that's how I still want to live like
a monk but it people may say when like
one thing about me you can realize I
shoot straight up how it is I'm a
straight shooter I basically I don't
like doing it I don't like social media
I can't stand it I can't stand being out
here all this stuff but I have a story
to tell and the only way you can tell
your story is through social media
platforms and do all these different
platforms and that's that's why I'm
doing it right see because I think I own
I was like this is not doesn't seem care
another consistent but I get it and
because the message is powerful and I
like you know so it sounds like you got
a little help like getting you all
configured on all that kind of stuff
right a lot of people come out to help
out and it's all about getting the
message out there man right and and the
message is strong and I'm glad that
you're doing it you know what I mean
it's it's not that social media itself
is bad
just what is your relationship to it
right you can just maintain your
integrity and your values and live the
life that the way that you want to live
and it doesn't interfere with that right
it's fine well one thing you'll see the
source of media I have up there is not
about me there may be some pictures
about me but there are this quotes about
you know videos just about mindset about
changing how you think about things
about not having to poopy pants
mentality to roll with me mentality and
just to make it clear it's not about
push yourself till you die some people
have this weird image of David Goggins
and that's what it's about
right no it's about push yourself a lot
harder than we think you can't push
yourself and stop giving up when you
feel a little bit of daggone pain or
something is uncomfortable no that's
what the message is that pushes up till
you can't live anymore
it's about this push support that we did
yesterday right believing you know
believing that your kid like what I
always say is like we're all sitting on
top of like huge reservoirs of untapped
potential right we don't even know are
even there you know that we don't even
attempt to tap into and so if you can
just expand your awareness a little bit
and understand that all of us
irrespective of circumstance is capable
of whatever of much more than whatever
it is that we're doing in the moment I
think that's right kind of at the core
of what you're trying to get a lot more
held a lot it would be 40% of a hell of
a lot more yeah so to put I want to get
into all the mindset stuff but I think
in order to put it all in proper context
it would be good to kind of trace your
story a little bit for people that are
listening who don't know who you are
so you know let's take it back a little
bit I mean you know kind of the crux of
your story sort of begins with the kind
of lone survivor story right right I'm
not sure you like tell me what was going
on well that's the beginning of my
ultrarunning
yeah that's like a phase like oh that
phase in my life basically I was a
bigger guy I just gone through I was in
three Navy SEAL hell weeks and so in
that in that period of time you meet a
lot of people a lot of good men going
through that you know that many times
why don't you three times
well that would be a lucky guy or very
unlucky I call it lucky depends how you
look at it so one year there happened
a time frame where the CEO the
commanding officer of Navy SEAL training
he was an old salty guy named captain
Bowen he was a Vietnam vet guy and
pretty much wherever you're at in
training and still cheating like like
I'm going to steal training in still
change twenty six weeks long no matter
where drugs yes but right so now where
you're at you if you get hurt or and you
couldn't continue on with training or if
you filled something he believed in
keeping you in training but he would
roll you back to day one mm-hmm so
generally if you get hurt in Phase two
of buds you get rolled back to day 1 to
phase two uh-huh
if you get hurt in Phase three you roll
back to phase three day one this guy
said no no we're going to roll you all
way back to day one phase 1 so Holly
went through three whole weeks was my
first time going through had a hernia
issue
double pneumonia pretty jacked up got
rolled out that whole week started day
one next class went to that full hell
week graduated a hell week a few weeks
after that hell week I broke my leg
started day one again but even though
you graduated they made you start again
yeah like I said you started day one I -
and you broke your leg because of like
just basically stress fractures from
going from zero to fracture right not
like like the log land on it up like
that and um so basically I get rolled
back to day one but usually nowadays if
you get hurt after hill week that's
where you stay right after heavy you
have to start from day one right I have
to be a few classes there that I was in
that they rolled you back to day one so
I was three times three times the
punishment and in my last hell week a a
guy died but I graduated that last time
to 35 class to 35 and you know went on
to do a few deployments and came home
and the the lone survivor story was
going on marcus luttrell was out there
in Operation Red Wings and I heard about
it I was about two hundred and sixty
some odd pounds whenever I was I don't
know the exact weight I was much heavier
and I want to raise money for families
man didn't you like know his brother
where you work you did buzz with his
brother
I was in faxing new Marcus first
thousand buzz with Marcus and Morgan
cause their Persaud I gone long so I
knew them both well and I was at
freefall school with this twin brother
Morgan during the incident so then the
exact time work Marcus was in the
incident I was at freefall school with
his twin brother and after we got there
with the last jump
we got notified that Marcus was missing
and the whole bunch of seals and also
special off guys had died mm-hmm so and
so the idea that was sort of sparked
inside you was I want to honor these
guys deaths and and try to raise
awareness and money for the families of
you know of these fallen victims right
and the best way that you came up with
to do this was to tackle the ten most
difficult endurance challenges on the
planet like where did that idea come
into your consciousness a lot of people
don't know my backstory how I grew up
and maybe will touch our base on it back
him up pretty rough you know I had a
very abusive father I grew up in a small
town called you know in Indiana that the
Klan headquarters was about 20 minutes
from where I lived
so um people talk about being bullied
now like somebody calls you fat and I
got called the n-word my whole my whole
childhood they sprinted it you know they
spray-painted on my car we're going to
kill you it was this a rough way to come
up and hey Dad not in the picture or dad
in the picture zone abusive I was born
and raised I was born in Buffalo New
York my dad was actually one the people
that helped Rick James become famous oh
wow so he actually grew up your friends
OJ Simpson and that was the kind of
crowd he he came up in so he's a very
abusive guy back to the point where by
like a party guy like a party guy but
also God that when he would drink he
would get very abusive okay you know he
would drag my mom down the stairs by her
hair when he didn't fight like Ike
Turner sterner stuff so he also do the
same thing to me my brother hmm you know
so yeah older brother older brother
uh-huh so had a rough way of growing up
had where where was mom and the whole
thing mom so mom was working the the
club with my dad and now it's eight or
nine we moved to this small town in
Indiana so to make ends meet she worked
three jobs and also in school full-time
mm-hmm so she was never around while I
was growing up and my brother stayed
with my dad so I was on my own Wow
dealing with this stuff growing up so if
in ages 6 years old age of 12 years old
you built self-esteem I had zero I was
pretty much the weakest kid on the
planet you're just getting like
emotionally beat down on a daily basis
and then yeah physical stuff with your
dad so you got emotional and physical
for my dad and then you leave that when
you're 8 or 9 and you go to this small
town in Indiana and you get called the N
word every day of your life you had the
you know Grand Wizard son at the Klan
sit behind you in history class so it's
a good time right so it was a it was a
you know I had to grow up a lot and and
I had a lot of excuses to not make a
damn thing of myself so and what was the
plan obviously as beyond just surviving
that at that time I didn't go to school
I had you know I was at a DD I had tons
of learning disabilities because I
didn't go to school it's not like I'm
with my father so I was very slow in
school so I had to learn all the high
school promotions in six months I
graduated to 39 to 14 in my graduating
class and I cheat on every daggone test
she's on every homework assignment and
that's I got to school and I had no
self-esteem whatsoever I have time I
want to go to school because I don't
even get called the n-word every day and
I hate even saying the n-word and so if
you all mine one said real work it
saying if you want good yeah I hate
being called [ __ ] all the time mmm you
know I was gonna keep as real as
possible so but that's what it was I
don't know when is the idea to go into
the military comment like to start with
I'm finishing high school or so I as a
young kid in high school also partners
program called Civil Air Patrol it's not
Ziller the Air Force like ROTC like
junior RTI right and I met this guy who
had a parachute accident he was an Air
Force special operator guy he had a
parachute accident pretty much died and
some Navy SEALs a funny story about that
he taught these two Navy SEALs and Hydra
tracheotomies those two Navy SEALs
actually saved his life the next day so
he had a parachute accident somebody
fell to his parachute when there
midair his parachute was wide open
somehow I was still a mystery fall went
through his parachute collapsed his
parachute knocked him out that's what
saved his life he was knocked out and he
fell to the ground and he actually was
you know hardly able to breathe these
guys tricked him open got a clear airway
got him breathing he got to the hospital
he died twice an operating table they
saved his life five years later I'm 16
years old 15 years old I meet this guy
at this camp and long story short I had
a well week with this guy along with all
these other white kids I was always
doing only black kid at all these dad
going camps so here I am with this guy
and I heard this story in it and I had
nothing to grasp growing up I had no
mentors I had no motivation had nothing
so I held on to that story and he became
my real-life Rambo I said that's what I
want to be I want to find that kind of
strength I had none grown up right so
basically I left that camp a week later
and a few months later you know this is
before Instagram and Twitter and Google
Leah faith all this crap I had a five or
six hundred our phone bill tracking this
guy down so I called he was the air for
special operators I called every Air
Force Base on the planet trying to call
this guy can hold us guys that is that
like the first time that you remember
like going after something in your life
like being really focused and and
intentional but I saw I found hope I
said oh yeah I saw way out this is way
out man I can actually get some
self-esteem I can actually gain some
manhood and be a look at myself in the
mirror versus being this coward that the
whole world had create I I let the whole
world create Who I who I was and how I
thought and that was the first mistake I
did but you had this idea inside of you
that that you wanted to be a man or your
idea of what a man was like that was
kind of what the quest of real that's
kind of behind all this it is in it and
it was like I saw myself as the weakest
human being on the planet and I wanted
to transform that into the hardest man
God ever created mm-hmm
basically and he always was funny about
that he laid the platform for me
he gave me nothing but I never said well
I love God I'm a god-fearing man so my
mind was never like God why me why this
why that he laid the platform for me to
be exactly who I wanted to be up and you
see the mindsets which versus me saying
what was me they called me [ __ ] they
didn't to beat me up they put [ __ ]
burger to you on my car all this stuff I
took all that stuff and instead of
making it well with me man my life sucks
Oh God why me why me I said oh the
platform is set you have that awareness
then or is that now something lady Nene
it came later once I met this guy and I
realized what I wanted to be and it that
awareness switched so I changed my
thought process versus kicking rocks
poopypants the rules that gives me
people are against me
they all suck and that's why I suck and
that's flipped it I've turned upside
down on top itself
yeah and it's funny because when you
look in the rearview mirror like the
dominoes line up perfectly for you to be
doing exactly what you're doing it's
almost like there's no other possible
narrative for you
they are the warrior mentality yeah so
most people who are even hearing this
today as we get talking a lot of stuff I
say they're going to say man you must
not love you said you must not have
peace no no no well you're going to hear
from my voice here soon it's passion
because why you're going to make me
relive my damn story yeah and what you
can hear out of me is me going back into
hell becoming the devil to get out of
hell so so what is what is that like
like how do you think about that
crucible process like whether it's buds
or whether it's bad water like that idea
of volunteering for that level of
suffering and the experience that you're
seeking and what you kind of receive on
the back end of that like how do you
think about that so how I think about it
is when I made the decision the
conscious decision to become a warrior I
realized that my mentality had to be
very different and what that meant was I
had to put myself through a bunch of
crucibles to gain the warrior mentality
some guys are born with it I believe
that some guys is born to they have some
great childhood in their - tough on them
and they build this mental toughness and
this discipline this kid I didn't have
this so I has designed a crucial
to put myself through to gain this
warrior mentality so what I mean by
worried mentality which is why some
people would take what I say so
literally they just say my god you're
just crazy you're gone no God had to put
some people on this planet earth to do
very dangerous things to protect this
country love it or not I'm one of those
people so to have the mentality that I
have to be in a room that ten by ten I
have a weapon I'm outside a door I don't
know what's behind that door so our job
as a still most of our time like most of
our job is to go behind open a door and
say surprise we're here the thing about
the surprise is I don't know what's
behind that door so they have that kind
of mindset to say I don't look at a 47
in the face repeatedly no kind of money
tastes open that door and not be afraid
to shut that door run away I was
building that Callos mind through these
things bad waters through so even after
I became a so I was still in the journey
to become a better warrior right and
these races and always if I thought
about being an ultra runner I saw first
of all about raising money but also the
selfish side of it always I was building
a warrior mentality but put myself in
the crucible of hell at Mile sixty of
135 mile race in bed water what are you
thinking blisters shin splints stress
fractures pee and blood maybe where you
could do now David how are you going to
get the next 70 miles in this race well
that's when you find out who you are
exact
to that moment it's all about that
moment and that decision that you have
to make when everything else is stripped
away from you right it's going to reveal
to you who you are exactly what your
character is and it was good about that
is a lot of people set these great goals
like they want to do bad water or they
want to do an Ironman or they want to be
a millionaire or whatever they want to
do that these great goal lists and their
amazing goals are important but what we
don't do in life which is why people
quit and still training and they quit in
these different things we don't look at
ourselves in the accountability mirror
and take care of the number one thing
before you start a goal let's take care
of our insecurities because they're
going to surface when you
put yourself in the crucible and you're
suffering you may be the best physically
fit person on the planet if you haven't
handled your mind and handled your
jealousies your insecurities
whatever happened to a child and in
between they're going to surface at the
time when your mind starts to question
why the hell am I here in this race
right because if you don't know why
you're doing it most people I would I
would venture to say that most people
that sign up for these things don't
really have a firm grip on why they're
doing it and more often than not it is
fueled by some insecurity or some sort
of you know ego issue right so that when
[ __ ] goes left there's nothing there
that's right I mean they can't grab a
[ __ ] up too right because the priorities
are kind of out of whack because there
is that disconnect with the real reason
or that kind of the appropriate healthy
drive if I get somebody doing Dustin
down vases healthy drugs that's true
what keeps a person in the fight is no
one is having purpose have a purpose
leave the ego at the door because the
ego will kill you every time you always
quit so that's why I was I've been able
to get through things because I know I
was a scared uneducated kid who
stuttered it had zero and I had to look
at myself in the mirror and hold myself
accountable for who I wasn't in who I
wanted to be mm-hmm and and that process
didn't didn't happen overnight and it
didn't happen through only three buds I
mean you on tours in Iraq and
Afghanistan you've also done Army Ranger
are you like I mean on Wikipedia it says
like you're the only guy in current well
not anymore she retired but current
Armed Forces who's who's done Rangers
Air Force fish loads and Air Force
Special Ops and truly yeah it's very
true that's crazy man no there would be
some kind of insane metal for that yeah
well that's the thing about it man like
you know it's kind of like you're you're
constantly looking for me everybody's
journey is different everybody's
Joanie's different I was on a journey to
see who David Goggins was and that
journey took me in some of the hardest
areas a human being can even
imagine and right now 41 I'm the
happiest person on the planet because
you know I had a climb Mount Everest
several times just to look down on my
life to see what hell I came from and
that's what kept me going through all
this stuff like I am visioning myself
going through like when I was a young
kid and they called me [ __ ] all times
I got my dad beat the hell out of me and
I was had no self-esteem I had this
vision of if I can make it to where I
want to go imagine when I look back on
my damn life how proud I will be and now
I'm here I'm able to look back on this
life I lived that many people will never
understand because why when you're
passionate they think you're crazy and
you can't even explain to people why
you're doing and why you did what you
did because you found your purpose and
once you find your purpose you can't
really explain it to normal people
because they don't understand passion
because they live everyday life is going
not really find their purpose so I've
become a foreign language to people I
think so they put me in a category if
you're just crazy no no no I'm
passionate I found my purpose in this
life yeah and you're embracing it you
know and you're and you're owning it
completely right right and that freaks
people out and why people aren't used to
that know what I mean no there's so much
packed into what you just said that I
want to kind of you know take a look at
I mean the first thing I want to talk
about happiness and your idea of
happiness but but one of the first
things you said is you know David
Goggins this like you're referring your
to yourself another percent always and
that's always like a little weird but I
know why you do it like your there's the
difference between kind of you know who
you are or like the eight year old David
Goggins and this sort of you know
Superman cape that you put on to become
this this sort of warrior mentality well
had to create Goggins because David
Goggins was a weak kid so I created
Goggins so the crucible of life that I
decided to take to become what I wanted
to become I created Gaga's Goggins is
the guy talking right now
David Goggins was a kid that got bullied
and all his other things and I created
Goggins mmm-hmm I created I was proud of
was
it was that like a conscious decision
you're like this is what I'm doing or
did that kind of you just come into that
oh this like sort of come into that
awareness like oh this is what I did I
didn't realize I was doing oh no it's
very conscious yeah it was very
conscious it was all internal
none of his external I don't care about
money I didn't care about awards
thanking about medals I don't care about
bad water I don't care about ultra
running these were all things for me to
build the extent that internal in myself
so like you know people don't don't get
it twisted man this is I did this to be
proud of Who I am as a human being and
most people live a lie I hated to lie I
lived in a lie I live was I was nothing
I knew I was nothing and my journey I
wanted to be some I want to be proud of
who I was and it took me in that
direction yeah I think this thing that's
that's sort of cool and unique about the
ultra distance world is that you know
they kind of these races exist pretty
much off the radar I mean they're
becoming more and more popular now right
it's not about like media attention and
there's no prize money and you know
Ultraman there's cars driving you know
the race and like all that kind of thing
right so the idea is that you're you're
you're really it's a race but you're
there to challenge yourself carry enough
at the end when you reach that finish
line whether you're a crew member
supporting somebody or you're the
athlete who's who's taking on this thing
for him him or herself that you are
transformed somehow right through the
result of you know undergoing that
experiment that's what it's about
like that more you talk about in 2013 18
yeah I walked 105 miles right I spent
seven hours in the vehicle from having
so many issues in my body ever goes why
didn't you quit man you could have
killed yourself it's not about that man
I'm not out here to kill myself you know
don't get it twisted man it was honestly
at that point it became a whole new
challenge the challenge is always to do
my best but at that point I saw my best
was done but that's well your best on
that day I mean whatever circumstance
yes God gave you that there was that so
I I took what God gave me that day and
said well I had to readjust the goals
and I found happiness in
and peace like okay man we're going to
reset this damn boy we're gonna walk a
hundred five miles right and we're going
to get to the finish line and you're
gonna walk a hundred and five miles of
bad water to be horrible and that's what
happened uh-huh so so how many out what
how many hours when you were did you
still make it under the 48-hour didn't I
I came up behind Dean oh you'd be like I
think he 40 minutes behind II yeah okay
20 mins behind II I was like 32 hours in
some check I was crazy Wow yeah I can't
be nice having a hard time too but but
you know he by no stretch of the
imagination did he walk on her I mean he
my was it all right you were walking
faster than anything you think you were
then well let's get into like where this
all began so you have this you have this
idea that you want to take on this
challenge right you find out about this
race bad water and I start naive to this
whole world and how it works
understatement is a life walk me through
it so like I said the whole Louis of
everything happened when I raise money
for the Special Operations Warrior
Foundation which the foundation that
gives a hundred percent tuition to
fallen Special Operations soldiers
children to go to school 100% so I found
a great foundation and I googled the ten
hardest races like you said in bad water
was number one and I thought it was a
stage race I thought the bad water 135
was a stage race where you would run
like 20 miles pitch at 10:00 or
something like that and cook out and go
run some more miles I didn't know you
can run a hundred miles at one time or
135 or whatever is humanly possible to
me I hadn't gone running over a year
head up running shoes on over a year and
you're like 280 and I was like I think I
was about 260 something I'm not for sure
I was over 250 I was a big boy and I
hated cardiovascular activities I want
to hit the weights and eat I was what I
did but I also want to do something that
would draw attention to this foundation
so I googled that race and I called
Chris kosslyn up the race director of
bad water and he thought I was nuts and
after he heard my story said he have a
Navy SEAL and he goes you got qualified
pretty much Chris Koster this particular
for his race
you got a qualify for bad water so I
call them up on a Wednesday in November
of
five and that Saturday was this race
called the San Diego one day where you
run 24 we went for 24 hours I run a
one-mile track mm-hmm
so he said hey you got qualified how he
qualifies you 100 miles in 24 hours or
less there happen to be two races before
the deadline of the bad water
application that things like January
19th of 2006 is when the deadline was up
so I call them in November I haven't
been training I have two months to
qualify for that water he said I will
consider you in my race if you can run a
hundred miles 24 hours so three days
later I find myself in San Diego one day
uh-huh
and I was married at the time and my
wife who's now my ex-wife was out there
and she was cruel me and I went to
Walmart got a blue lawn chair mile Plex
and rich crackers right and that's what
the hell I have nestlings but no
training zero haha and and people can
think it's 0 right 0 training zero so
here I am now I'm out here on this big
black guy around all these ultra runners
who it's the a you a national
championships in San Diego and I'm out
here running and I get to mile 50 40 50
and I start to break the bones in my
feet and they're they're horribly broken
stretch fracture shin splints I'm in bad
shape and at Mile 70 I sit down for the
first time I haven't peed or gone to the
bathroom at all in over 13 12 13 14
hours I sit down and my blood pressure
now is messed up because my potassium
electrolytes all the things that you
need in your body food I had nothing
right near ex-wife said nurse right
right so she'd monitoring you and she's
monitoring me looking at me like you
know what man what do you matter we were
really in the dungeon and I was it was a
worship have been in my entire life
all the things I've been through in the
military this was the worst that ever
endured so I'm all 70 I sit down and I
can't get up not to go to the bathroom
so once you sit down you think it's over
so now the pains really going with my
body and the porta-potties you know 70
miles in like 13 hours I think we talked
about yeah yeah yeah so I was actually
moved free will forget a big boy so I
get there and I'm at 70 miles and half
to go so I'm pretty good with myself but
now I'm really messed up and I sit down
and is the worst thing I did my rent was
over once you sit down it was over man
so looking at my wife ex-wife now and I
couldn't gather the chair so I literally
pee blood down my leg and took a crap up
my back and that was a whole new race
now and but I figure out a way to make
this big ordeal which was 30 more miles
and so the worst pain I've gone through
so what got you up out of the chair
honestly I create this thing called the
cookie jar as I went through my
suffering in life to become who I was
and the cookie jar was every time I
failed everything so many times in my
life and failure and I would succeed I
would fail than I would succeed had to
figure out how to succeed to failure and
I put a bunch of cookies in the cookie
jar cookie jars of things when I start
to get the what was me mentality which
we all still get even though you know
you could be very successful I reach
there and I saw this is my childhood and
this is what I did to overcome that I
would remind myself so because lot of
times we are in hell you forget how
great you really are because at that
moment you're suffering so you know you
don't think about the great things that
you've done I take time to really calm
my brain down when it's stressed out and
remember where I came from
instead okay no we can do this we can do
this to a calm patient mind figuring out
how to do it so I figured out how to do
it how to get salt electrolytes get some
food get some hydration back in me get
my blood pressure support I can stand up
that was the first mission and you still
you got half a day to get right 30 miles
out yeah and we all know we can walk 30
miles in 12 hours but think about it my
feet were broken pretty badly down so
but anyway I got on a chair was every
get up and I was walking like a 37
minute mile and at that pace I wasn't
going to make the time and my ex-wife
said hey you're not gonna make time in
at Mile 81 never forget it this is when
I truly realized I've been through a lot
before this this and I realized how far
short we have come as human beings by
whenever we feel pain and we
suffer a little bit we stopped and I
didn't stop and my brain knew I wasn't
going to stop and went to a whole nother
place when she said I wasn't going to
make the time and my 81 I ran the last
19 miles safe and that's when at that
point in my life that's when I knew boy
I really really need to rethink the
capabilities of a human being it's
interesting that that's really your
first like you know ultra athletic feat
or attempt and to this day you know in
the wake of like a resume of doing a
million of these things and all kinds of
crazy stuff like that's still I would
have I would imagine like perhaps the
most memorable and most difficult thing
you've ever done
don't imagine yeah it should be yeah
uh-huh
by far yeah it's amazing I had to go to
places that I didn't even know existed
within my brain to overcome such
suffering and like a what do you think
like what is it that you have that other
people lack like what is the facility or
the the mindset that you're able to get
into that allows you to click in and say
I'm going to run this last 19 miles as
opposed to what most people would say
which is I'm done you know what if
there's a lot of answers for that but
once again it once you find my purpose
was pretty much at that time to raise
money for a foundation but I can't say
that that was my only driving force when
you're in that much pain I'm sorry
you're not thinking about raising money
for a foundation I'm sorry I'm human I
had to go dark and going dark was I had
to go to that straight barbaric
garanimal mindset of like as bad as I
was suffering the suffering I had to
make it work to my advantage I had to
enjoy I'd embrace the suffering I didn't
really see man up now I'm at Mile 70
I've never gone 70 miles before what if
I can go 30 more miles in this situation
I'd talk to myself very differently
versus being scared of what I was doing
in my body because if I thought that way
which a normal person should think that
way but once again
I have a warrior's mentality I thought
the exact opposite what if I get through
this being this messed up and it sparks
my endorphins to say if I can go 100
mile or 30 more miles this messed up
where most human beings we couldn't I
did the what-if right and I saw myself
finishing this race and the feeling I
would have after I finished it in a got
me through it most people would say well
here's the glutton for punishment right
what is it you know what is this
masochistic relationship to suffering
all about like what are you getting out
of it and you know I think I know your
answer but but I think that question is
as much a reflection of where we're at
as a society right as much as it is you
know an answer or a comment on you as an
outlier right and that's why I always
say before I start any interview in that
this is one reason why I did my own
social media because people would take
exactly what I said to you because why
most people haven't found what they're
passionate about I did and I was
passionate about David Goggins in this
journey my journey it was not your
journey anybody's my journey in my
journey with the sea
how far can I go I came from nothing I
had nothing I had nothing no great
mentality no great family no great
education no great you know I have
sickle cell you know I had to hold my
heart the size of a poker chip had two
hearts or had nothing and my journey was
to see what I was capable of so it
wasn't like being a masochist
nothing like that it was the fact that I
want to see who the best me was and I
wasn't willing to settle for stopping at
70 miles right now I'm very glad that I
don't do that anymore
like I don't have that in me anymore at
that time of my life I was looking for
myself and like I said for myself it
what about being a masochist because it
hurt yeah I didn't like the pain it was
real it was real to me I'm not a crazy
guy I'm not a masochist I'm a guy that
better for myself and if you're willing
to live yeah it doesn't take you running
a hundred miles then take you running on
broken feet then take you having all
these things I had to run through for me
it did right everybody has their version
of what I have and you know this kind of
gets into a little bit like what I what
I wanted to get into do before which is
like how do you conceptualize happiness
right so where is culture where
basically we're inundated with messaging
and that message is you know in order to
be happy you won't you need a super big
TV and you need you know you need to be
secure in your job and you write around
yourself with all these material
possessions and you want to be as
comfortable as possible and and sort of
you know live in luxury right like this
is the aspiration of the American Dream
right and and in contrast to that you're
experiencing a level of happiness that
most people can't access and you're
doing it in a very kind of Spartan stoic
way by living this minimal lifestyle and
pushing yourself to be constantly you
know perpetually out of your comfort
zone to continually you know sort of
test yourself and try to expand your
horizon right right so like how do you
think about that and talk about that
well I did that for a period of time so
I lived a Spartan lifestyle for other
Spartan mine now uh-huh but I'm retired
yeah I did a similar two weeks ago so
this let's be clear that's not my life
that was never my life
I'm in a whole different journey now
yeah you're not going to moot you're not
going to move to Beverly Hills and get
some big swag not like I don't see you
changing you're not going to become a
different person well I will tell you
this I am interesting and while I will
tell you this we all have a journey
uh-huh that journey for me is over yeah
I will always work out I will always
have the Spartan mind I always say stop
feeling sorry for your damn self get the
hell up because I know what you can do
that part of my life so the whole part
of the journey is it gets the part where
you find peace once you find peace and
your journey may be bigger than your you
can do anything you can go anywhere
exactly
once you realize why America's going to
continue to did I now know for 100% fact
I can do anything I want to do I'm going
to fail probably a million times trying
to do it but I guarantee one thing you
will then read about 20 years from now
David Goggins doing we set out to do and
he failed for 20 years you're reading a
peb death son of a [ __ ] actually did it
because I know I can
uh-huh I know I threw out way kick but
so what isn't it what is it what's the
next thing right now the whole thing now
is why I'm on social media because now I
figured out how a human being can endure
more than what they think is possible
with nothing like people think you need
great parents need grazing all this
stuff I think you need to have all this
stuff and they have this thing like well
maybe it wasn't meant to be if I had
that mindset one damn time my life I'd
be a 400-pound man spraying for
cockroaches still right so my whole
thing is now I know how to think
properly to be successful in all kind of
aspects of life and it's not about
ultrarunning
nobody's being a seal it's not about
pull up records or anything like that
it's about if you want to be better you
have to change the way you your
perceived limitations and take the
barriers down and I think that gets that
kind of dovetails nicely into this idea
of of purpose and finding your purpose
like you said most people don't you know
most people don't know what their
purpose is and and I think there's a lot
of confusion between purpose and being
purposeful versus like inspiration or
motivation right so I know like on
social media our tagline is like beyond
motivation right sort of you know
unpacking the inherent limitations of
motivation versus purpose right
motivation is crap like right now
there's people out here right now who's
going to hear this podcast and maybe
they'll think we think whatever you want
to about David guy I don't care kind of
the truth I know the truth I know that
my journey sucked and I didn't like it I
didn't want to be a seal I didn't want
to be a ranger I hate
I'm afraid of heights I'm afraid of cold
dark water that I was only 36
african-american in 70 years become a
seal right okay okay our 300 pounds
twice in my life um so basically and you
hate running and I hate running but
people people would say everyday they
tell me all the time a feature yeah but
you know it's Oh believe what you want
think I'm crazy because while you think
this because you can't see yourself
going further than what you can so you
want to put a tag on David Gardner's
will tag me I'm sorry to say I say
beyond motivated because it takes that
to be successful I may motivate you
right now if you're living in Chicago
and it's -2° and I motivate you to get
out of your house and go run two miles
but that wind chill hit your face once
you go outside that motivation is going
to go away real fast you go back inside
and suggesting that couch a person
that's driven and passionate they go
outside so that windchill they go back
inside to get a new hat because I'm
going to get my damn running today right
so how do you how do you people find
that you know what if they left it's
their own thing man the own thing but
you have to get in a quiet place in your
brain we all live on our bones we all
live in Google we all live in in this
whole social media world that I really
hate I absolutely hate it and yeah I'm
on it I'm on it but look at my messages
my message the motivation to be better
it's not about look at me look at me
look at this no it's about me knowing
what it takes to be better then I became
a master at the mind I'm trying to share
it so I'm trying to do while you can't
find purpose because in your head
there's a bunch of noise when I was
younger growing up they called me this
they call me that I had all that noise
in there
the second I put on the kind of
quote/unquote Bose headphones in silence
the noise I listened to my internal
voice half of us live our whole lives
and never even listened to what the hell
we want to do how do you get fire
purpose when you don't even know who the
hell you are because you're trying to
find yourself through other avenues of
well we're just reacting mindlessly to
the circumstances
that were presented with right and I
think I think really what you're saying
is you got it you've got to invest in
yourself it's an inside job like you
have to connect with who you write in
order to do that you do have to get
quiet because you have to be able to
discern the difference between those
external messages right that you're
unconsciously you're unaware are
motivating all of your actions right and
to connect with the person inside of you
that stands apart from that and what
that means and what that voice is I
start to cultivate that and yeah you
can't do it when you're constantly
checking Twitter or when someone's
screaming at you all day right right it
was funny about that is why I'm so
misunderstood because so few people have
found their passion and found why the
hell they're on this planet and once you
find it you will then oh maybe David
when I was you know crazy you don't give
a [ __ ] what anyone saying then you're
not on social media because you're doing
your thing right you know to Meriden I
was trying to take anyone else down and
that's exactly it
you're not trying to put them in a
category to make yourself feel better
you now understand why this guy did what
he did because he found his purpose in
his life and that's that's it right so
all right so you broke all your feet but
then so you got to call up Kozma and
tell them you ran 100 miles or so after
I call it so after I get through 100
miles in 18 hours and 56 minutes I
called Chris cost me I'm not going to
tell you how bad off I was I was really
jacked up and I called Chris Kaufman and
I said hey man I'm home like that night
like it was out next morning and by the
way this is where Jesse Itzler was there
right the whole believe having the whole
thing yeah came from that so so here I
am now our call Chris cost me up in
Chris Kaufman like I said the stickler
for his race and he said the whole idea
of a 24-hour race is to run 24 hours and
that's like the perfect message for you
and that's right
because I because I stopped it I got a
hundred watch yeah he did a hundred
miles 24 hours I got a hydrant use on me
an hour yeah six hours why did you stop
and so I said exactly I'm in the race so
there's one more race I could do and I
have broken feet
I was all jacked up and it was called
the hurt 100 very few people complete to
hurt 100 it's a brutal racing hardest
races in the world in the world and this
was my second race I've ever done and it
was a two months later and hurt 100 100
miles over almost 26 27 thousand feet of
climbing in this jungle in Hawaii and
it's brutal
it's almost unrunnable and it's just
treacherous man it's horrible and I in
the deadline was January January 19th
I finished the race January 17th I was
in I was in a wheelchair with my ex-wife
doing the five pace application process
overnight it to Chris Kaufman he got it
and he's like you you're very driven man
and I mean the race so you ran hurt 100
the feet are still broken right and then
bad water is July July July so we're the
feet healed up by no if you look at if
you look at pictures of me look at
pictures of my ankles you see this
compression take so how I end up running
to train for bad one had this
compression tape on that kept me in my
shins nice and tight and I had these big
pressure ulcers because the tape was dug
in and anyway that's how I ran I can
only run about 30 to 40 miles a week
training it for bad water because I'm so
broken and how did you even like
approach the idea of okay so now I'm in
and I've got this block of time like how
do I maximize that to be as best
prepared as I can like did you get a
coach or did you just go and feel like I
know you just you just go out and go no
I knew the race sucked I knew was hot
and I've never had a coach in my life
and I just started training hard right
and I started training more of my mind
you get did you get the treadmill and
the sauna thing no but I did do a lot of
sauna training like workouts process
push up stuff like that I spent a lot of
time in a sauna but I couldn't run that
much because my feet were so broken I
did a lot of time analytical trainer I
did hours on the elliptical I did hours
high
he was big rucksacks on and I just
trained very barbaric because the race
was barbaric to me wasn't much about
running in the first year I did bad when
I got fifth place but once again I
walked most of it I just walked hard
yeah I did I didn't stop at all I just
walked hard I just walked real hard and
I got fifth place in the third year
second I came back and I got third place
didn't like 25 hours right so yeah it's
amazing and you know everyone knows
about the heat at bad water but a lot of
people under appreciate the elevation
game like there's some serious climbing
in that in that brain there is but you
know when after you did hurt 100 before
bad water
it didn't really like 30 26 thousand
feet versus 13 some thousand even the
last the last 13 up whitney that climb
sucked but it's on a road yeah and you
can actually get that nice grip with
your feet and actually getting a nice
rhythm of just walking mm-hmm and you
know the race sucks trust me but after
you hurt 100 in this dark jungle where
you can't see pitch dark in front of you
and you're up and down like a like an
EKG the whole race like EKG up and down
that Salomon race profile looks it
really put bad water it sucked
bad water it was horrible but hurt 100
is writing bad and after the first bad
water I think three months later was
Ultraman right like you just went
straight away right into the November or
whenever OSHA man was I know I I did
either borrow a bike from a friend I
trained for like three weeks on the bike
and I went off to the Ultraman and I and
I had I do not say the tiger why I
didn't win that race was got a second in
the race and I should I I should have
won I lost 30 minutes on the bike
because I couldn't change a tiger so
what happened was I was waiting for the
for this the vehicle to come up to
change my tire so I got this spare bike
out the back of the car and it didn't
have any clips on it so I had my running
I had my running shoes in the back of my
running shoes on and put the little
petals on and just rolled the bikes for
the next 75 miles with just pedals on
uh-huh and I end up the day three III
one day three the actual running part
and I missed first place by 10 minutes
yeah it's crazy that run
is uh that's quite something man that
you did that I'm surprising to go back
and try to win it well you know what I I
hated the race yeah you know I here's
the thing like you're for most people
and I would include myself in this
category like the idea of tackling one
of those races like could be a life
defining thing and it's something that
like you orient your whole life and you
just kind of approach these like it's
another workout man like I did that
what's next yeah I was looking forward
you know you parachuted into the
beginning of the Ironman right and then
you did the Ironman and then I think he
worked out after that was done like it's
another workout I'm moving forward and
was funny about that is in 2007 I
actually did I think seven or eight
consecutive in consecutive weekends
hundred mile races uh-huh and these runs
and Molitor was like the bear one
hundred angels crest Leadville I had
done bad water you know before that I
did a western states before Balor so
frequency for better I did western
states then after that I went to
Leadville in August and after that I
went right to oh the plane one hundred a
social support 100 mile race Angels
crest I said the bear then the fitness
ex-59 races in that year and then ended
that year running tours and five miles
around at the grapevine texas right and
they were workouts there's an aim for
anybody else like their whole season
would be oriented around just one of
those right right and yours going from
thing to thing to thing so so I'm trying
to get a sense of you know obviously
like the exceptionalism of your mindset
and your mental approach to all of this
but on some level like I know that you
kind of categorize or think of yourself
as like look I'm an average dude you
know I'm tough but like I was 300 pounds
right but there has to be some sort of
you know I mean are you willing to like
entertain the possibility that you do
have like some talent is it doing this
or is it all like you're chalking it all
up to preparation of mine well like I
said if anybody's familiar with sickle
cell it's a blood disease that pretty
much it's called sudden death syndrome a
lot of african-americans you have it
they pass out and die so you know my vo2
Max is horrible my hematocrit and all
this stuff is horrible and also having a
hole in your heart that that decides I
had it took away a lot of money on this
thing like you have like you have like
you're operating with like only like 25%
of your capability that's what I'm
trying to tell people right now tonight
Opie but everybody thinks that they they
want to believe and I wish I was after
every race I was either in a in a
wheelchair or whatever because whenever
sickle cell is just not the smartest
thing to do those those distances at
mile 50 of every hundred mile race man I
was destroyed and I just had to find but
the feeling of the next 50 miles I had
to go I learned a lot about David Goggin
in the will there's always me it gets me
so no I don't have any ability see this
is the heart of the whole thing though
because I think it's really important
because if you are a genetic freak of
nature then it's very easy for somebody
to shrug you off like oh yeah well he
does it but like you know he's who he's
David Goggins right I mean like normal
people can't do that and for you to
always anchor it and bring it back to
look man these are the challenges of
impressing I'm facing I have to overcome
more of these challenge right and the
average guy like I'm actually starting
at a deficit right us and I'm not going
to ever let anybody make themselves feel
better by telling me that I was some
genetic freak I'm not going to make
yourself feel better about that you I
suffered and I always say suffer because
that's what I did it was miserable the
races every single race in Hill week and
budge in the Ranger School I suffered
tremendously I was not I should never
have been able to do it which is why I'm
so proud of myself I don't care what
place I came in I don't care walk the
Huntsman five miles of bad water um I
did it mm-hmm that was the journey that
was a mission that was about it's not
about oh well this guy is just a freak
if that makes you feel that's fine no
you can do it up just a breath of air in
the right mindset that's the message
so you you watered-down my message by
putting me in a category if I'm crazy
I'm a freak
whatever well all of those all of those
arguments are comfortable arguments to
allow people to stay stuck in whatever
situation you know it means right so
it's more uncomfortable if they have to
actually reckon and wrestle with the
fact that you are like them just like
them and no one won't want to do that
you know I look in the mirror right and
right so tell me about the mirror thing
is a big thing with you right it's a
huge thing for me it's called the
accountability mirror so I talked to my
childhood and if anybody thinks I'm some
great person listen to my childhood
again I had to change my thinking
process and basically the accountability
mirrors we did it I started shaving my
head in my face when I was 16 years old
and I realized when I started shaving my
face in my head I you have a lot of time
to look at your reflection and for some
spark to mimic man I'm a piece of crap
like I abduct school abducts court
barely in graduating I'm on this I'm
this I'm this I'm all these things man
and I had to really tell myself the
truth and so many people when you say
you're dumb the first thing people say
oh no you're not if you're dumb you're
dumb if you're fat you're fat but if
you're not willing to tell yourself that
and everybody around you in your circle
it continues to give you this positive
feedback if you suck you suck if you
tell yourself you're suck that is when
you become great well then you're
getting into the solution that is what
I'm talking about
so that accountability meter was I got
to become I got to get to the surface of
who I'm not and I held myself
accountable
I lied to this person today I'm a liar
I'm a cheater I'm this I'm that and I
tell myself and I fix these issues and
fix these issues and that part was hard
it was hard to not be jealous of this
person who have this and this and this
had nothing nothing it was hard to tell
this person yeah I'm Joseph you and I'm
insecure I'm a very insecure guy and I
have nothing it was hard to
I'm not real smart and I had but I had
to fix these issues and the
accountability mirror was now look at
myself in the mirror and said well you
fix these issues right so that's the
thing that you like consciously practice
every day every day my line the mirror
every day life even now so if I were to
say some little white lie and I go to
the mirror in the morning time I say me
as I'm an why the hell did you say that
guy and he would get a call from me and
said look dude I I I lost like that's
like 12 stuff BAM it's like doing your
daily inventory
I like making amends for your [ __ ] I
said you know I mean because you lied to
you so when you see like this you know
we're in this cultural malaise right now
we're like every kid gets a
participation trophy like we have to
tell everyone that they're great right
now you know what I mean it's all about
like feelings and everybody's a special
snowflake and all right that like you
know that must make you insane it makes
me more than insane it really it's the
destruction of this kind of this country
and I love this country I've fought hard
for it I will continue to fight forward
and hopefully through mental toughness
it takes middle toughness to change how
you look at things and given a personal
trophy saying you're great when you're
really not if I had that growing up
there would be no David Goggins zero
there we know tough people none which is
why the world is where it is today a bus
a week some weak people right there's a
lot of weak people now right so right
now there's a lot more awareness about
what a seal is and what a seal does
because of Hollywood right I mean like
there's a bright white spotlight being
shined on like SEAL Team six and
American sniper and like all of this
right informs our awareness of what this
is right so what is what is the reality
versus like what were presented like
what do we what do you wish like people
understood about what it actually is
like to be you know to do what you do
like when you're deployed right a great
question
and once again that will help people who
want to put me in a category maybe I am
in a category I'm in a very small
category of warriors real warriors and I
want to say that is a whole different
mentality so I've worked with people who
had the courage to jump on grenades and
killed themselves to save everybody
around them that's the kind of mentality
it takes to be a seal that does every
Navy still have it no but that's what
seals are that's what we try to that's
why Navy SEAL training buds is so hard
we're trying to find that person who's
willing to go the distance and the
distance is your life so when I'm
talking to people right now maybe what I
say to you does not resonate because
while you're not willing to give your
life for something every field at least
most I can't speak for everyone most of
us are a lot of people go fight for this
country
a lot of them are not willing to do that
am i talking bad about no don't take it
and twist my words if you like to twist
words I thank you for your sacrifice I
thank you for that a lot of people are
scared Navy SEALs are scared also but a
lot of us have a way to realize what we
have decided to do with our lives and it
takes a great sacrifice that sacrifice
could be your life and that you have to
be able to do that to become a warrior
if you go into combat scared you can be
scared but you can't be so scared it
makes you afraid to fight that makes
sense we're able to control that and all
of us are able to put ourselves in hell
and become the devil do you think that
your your sense of purpose and like your
your your sense of like clear direction
for your life has allowed you to you
know whether those experiences and come
back and like not suffer some of the
sort of traumatic stress that you hear
about with a lot of veterans definitely
yeah um I've already I had PTSD a long
time ago you know you can get it in war
you can get in life and you have to deal
and a lot of people cannot deal with it
and you have to be able to deal with
these things and realize I built up a
pretty hard like I have a whole bunch of
calluses on my hands for doing pull
also calloused my brain through my life
through suffering through not saying no
for not listening to the negative energy
to negative people and when you continue
to move forward through hell and move
forward past your fears and insecurities
and continue to push through this wall
your brain becomes really callous and
you're able to see things that most
people came to comprehend because you
always you never ran from the fight you
ran to the fighting and that builds a
different kind of mindset that allowed
me to do with very very tough things do
you think that somebody can adopt that
level of discipline or at least a
modicum of the level of discipline that
you hold yourself to it hold yourself
accountable to without having suffered
the kind of you know pain that you've
had to go through you know I mean like
it's like pains the greatest motivator
right you know to me mentally and
physically just I'm like you don't you
don't have to be in pain to change so
that most people don't change unless
they're in pain right right right I
believe you can but it truly takes you
wanting and that's the thing about it
man like you really have to want
something bad that's the one thing I
learned about life you have to be
willing to fail a hundred times to
succeed once if you're not going to do
that man you're not going to even get a
fraction of what you're looking for
I think we need to rethink how we frame
failure like I don't even like that word
you know I mean because it implies such
a negative you know outcome or
perspective like it should just be it's
there should be a different word for it
and then I wouldn't be so caught up in
it right I mean you know what what she
said is so true that word doesn't bother
me because I look at it like you are
trying to say it phrase failure is just
a word for me
failure was me having more information
on how to succeed that's all failure
became to me so I feel so much pull-up
records running events has equipped this
buzz brain just all this crap had to go
back through all that was was oh
I felt because of these reasons here go
back to the drawing board figure out the
right equation and put together go back
fail again oh I got more information you
just neutralize it like it should be if
you if you replace 'if ale you replace
it with the word tri or something like
that but ever you want whatever you know
what I mean and and and just drain it of
all of that like right and negative you
know energy a rosca suck it up and say I
failed to say feel so good weird about
yeah I mean like uniting so yeah so how
do you I mean what would you like what
is your weakness like what's your blind
spot your Achilles heel well because the
works never done right like so what's
what do you what do you still need to
work on um like I said I was afraid of
the water afraid about all these things
I was afraid of so everything I was
afraid of I made sure to meet it right
in the face and overcome it right now
what I'm working on now is learning how
most people think because my whole thing
why I was hardly going social media
because why people would give me this
week crap and I absolutely cannot
understand my freaking mentality so I
would just go off because I would go
back to where I came from and I would
approach you in a way that was garanimal
animalistic like what is wrong why don't
you go somewhere in your mind where you
find out who the hell you are and then
it's 3:00 in the morning and you're like
going back and forth yeah someone so I'm
going off and I have realized that
there's very few people if any that have
done what you've done mentally so I had
to go back and I'm always better in how
I think people will change their car go
change their underwear though change
your husband their wife their change
their diet but very few people change
the way they think and that's why they
always [ __ ] themselves in life they
never change the way they think oh my
house is old I don't get a new house I'm
gonna get a new pair of they're so
that but the one thing we never changed
while we always stay the damn same and
never wonder why we're getting better
because we never change the way we think
I'm constantly changing the way I think
the core of Who I am
I'll never change that I'm proud of that
warrior Spartan mentality but how I deal
with people how you can touch people ya
know with what they respond to then
everybody's respond to me saying look
get the [ __ ] up man stop being a little
punk I got to see what's wrong with you
think now I'm thank him and then tell
you what not what you want to hear but
kind of what's going to motivate you
we're all motivated very differently
that's so interesting
Robert I mean it's interesting that you
can get provoked by some troll on the
Internet
you know what I mean somebody who's a
master of emotional discipline right so
I think that you just you just shouldn't
be you should be putting out your
message and you should not be reading
any other comments well I'm not provoked
by it what it is like if you're you're
confused right you feel compelled to
respond well when you're passionate
about something and someone's trying to
tell you what you're thinking like a lot
of people some people tell me well do
you find love in your life or are you
happy with who you are and that's very
loaded right that's like my eating
question so it's just like I can't
believe you the thing but what sets me
off you set me off was just honestly
people reading into something because we
overthink everything stop overthinking
psyche get the hell out there and do it
yeah that's the internet though like
like welcome to the internet which is
why yeah I don't like it which is why I
was never on your positive message out
and just don't engage well other aspect
of it that's what I've done so yeah
that's what I've done but there's give
me times in my life where some people
just need to hear something from a
different person because it may may like
I said thinking it may change the way
you think
if you ignore all those comments which I
do most of them some of them you've got
attackers why I might put a spark in
your brain
- maybe you may think to yourself Wow
hmm I just changed my life right so if
you ignore all of them your knowing the
fact of why I am on social media right -
now tell you how I'm thinking and not
just hear the weaksauce you have that
you're bringing my way I get it man
you just you got to get you got to get a
book done alright I'm in the process
right now writing this book that I've
been asked for several years to write
and I'm just putting my stuff in there
man but if you you know so I'm doing
that's good so I'm doing so what is how
has a lot of people asked this and want
to know how your diet has evolved and
changed over over time like from going
from doing you know back to back hundred
mile or right you kind of what you're
doing now I have several different diets
because I'm doing I'm constantly tapping
my body in several different ways if I'm
not running a hundred mile race I'm a
guy that's doing like 4,000 push-ups in
a day or I'm a guy that's trying to do I
did 67,000 pull-ups in nine months to
train for the pull-up record huh huh so
he bugs it still stand I was 2013 I
don't think it still stands nothing sir
but I know that if it doesn't stand I'm
not going for it again Merry Christmas
you gotta have it so you did it you did
it what the thing he did on The Today
Show that was like 2011 right no it was
actually 2012 well so I did a pull-up
record attempt failed miserably two
months later and so I did one in um
September did another one in November
didn't know when I finally got it in
January right so it was two months off
failed two months off fail pass right
4,000 34,000 third
17 hours a while you know say man so
much I honestly changed and um and I
don't you know I don't really talk about
diet too much man because it's just
always changing but it depends I'm doing
I'm a big protein guy I'm a big me no
acid guy but I don't really get in the
weeds with all this diet stuff you know
I keep a lot of things still secret to
myself
everybody wanted to beat it around diet
everybody was no diet yeah everyone's no
diet well it's it's that's I'm asking
you mainly because like you saw the
tweets I think like ever that's whatever
wants them ya know what I mean
but I think the bigger issue is like if
you tell me what David's morning routine
is or if you tell me exactly what his
training program is or you tell me
exactly how he eats then I can be David
Goggins or I can automate I can
approximate some respect I can I can
bring a little bit of David Goggins into
my life right and for me it's missing
the most important thing if the mind is
going back to mindset it's like
connecting with yourself that's all it
is what is it that that gets you out of
bed like how can you find that part it's
not about what David does in our
learning routine or whether the workout
is it's about you and your relationship
to yourself you said right period dot
it's not about what David's eating is
not about what anybody eating once you
figure out who you are hopefully you get
one thing for me today change the way
you are thinking don't put but if you're
but if you listen I'm just trying to get
in the in I'm trying to get into the
head of the guy who sitting at his
cubicle at work right who's hating his
life right and David's telling me I got
to change the way I think well like what
the [ __ ] do I do with that like I don't
I don't understand what I'm supposed to
actually but what you do what you're
supposed to do is everybody has issues
you're a human being you're [ __ ] up
somewhere and that somewhere or several
somewheres is keeping you in that same
spot like the spot is this how do you
lose a hundred pounds how do you run a
hundred miles how are you how do you how
do you how do you let me tell you how
stop asking these [ __ ] questions is
how stop you're delaying the [ __ ]
process by wasting my [ __ ] time how I
did it I wanted it so my process was as
I'm asking questions I'm running to lose
weight I'm figuring out how to do it
most of us sit back and said god I wish
I could do that and we wait and we wait
and we ask more
it has more questions in prolong even
what kind of watch are you wearing what
kind of running is like they're not
going to God and run until they got all
the answer you know all this stuff right
or who's a you know what is your
approach to this thing right and I look
at you and I'm like this guy wanted to
do bad water you know a week later he's
running 100 miles on a track about
nothing
that's exactly that you had you had
Drive and you had a vision and you had
passion and you went after it and you
had not only did you not have the
answers you weren't even asking the
questions yet I don't care because and
this the thing about it like and that's
what's so fun of you and that's why I
get so turned off by people like that I
get it you have to have knowledge to be
great at something and to lose weight to
be as smart as you have knowledge
knowledge is power
I'm going to tell you right now man how
much damn knowledge do you need you can
go on internet right now and figure out
how to drop five pounds tomorrow
everything is right there at your
service if you want it you will achieve
it
but if you want to waste time and figure
out ask all these [ __ ] questions I'm
gonna give you the same answer
stop asking the question in chief what
you want if I asked a bunch of quest I
was still trying to figure out how to
run a hundred miles so many people tell
me I would love to run bad water one day
why the [ __ ] haven't you done it you
told me that five years ago I wonder I
didn't I did it on bad water I did it in
four months I qualified in four days and
ran the damn race I wanted to be a Navy
SEAL he'll lose a hundred five pounds in
60 days to get in and do it I lost the
weight and became a damn seal I wanted
to be a ranger at 41 years old people
couldn't even do next I don't know I've
already done it because the second I
thought about it i resourced it
I'd ask questions I achieved it we waste
tons of time not starting our journey
for asking so many [ __ ] questions on
how to start the journey get an idea
start walking and figure this [ __ ] out
as you go Vision Quest but David you
don't understand my life thanks Daniel I
got I got you know I were I have to get
up at 5:00 and I never tell not
mine and I got three kids I'm barely
making ends meet like it's cool that you
can do that but like that's you know
it's just not possible what I love about
that is people can come at me with all
that crap all day long when I say that
right there to you I was a full time
Navy SEAL there's 24 hours in the day I
will do an ultra races and how I did it
was at a be at work at seven o'clock in
the morning I woke up at 3 o'clock in
the morning I ran and then I rode my
bike to work and I did the same thing
and I came home if you want it you will
find time in your life to do it if you
don't want it you will continue to do
exactly do I now give me excuses you're
going to make it every excuse and why
you can't do it and that's why I can't
connect it to you that's why you hear
the passion come out of me and you want
to say it's anger no because I know it
can be done and you're telling me all
this [ __ ] on why it can't be done
and then you what you do is he's crazy
he's in the CAG no you don't want it bad
enough if you want it bad enough you
will figure out how to make this [ __ ]
happen and most people don't want
anything bad enough no I think that's
the truth very unfortunate sad true
that's good for me though I'll take it
all yeah I'll take it all now let's tell
you about right now when I grew up on 41
years old and we all asked about the old
days it's not I'm not old but it was a
different time parents they actually
whip their kids next had things like
that going on if ours was my mentality
today if I was born now with my
mentality today it'd be such an easy
easy way to go so easy you just crush
crush every body snowflake everybody
melt so really I would have so much
stuff for me because why so easy to
compute these guys you can crack
somebody you can crack your will in a
second you're fat oh my god what was me
you can crack someone in a minute
because they don't know how to twist it
and find Drive and motivation and
passion to become better to become great
that right there you tell one kid he's
fat that may stick with him the rest of
his life and take him down a whole
nother journey than the journey supposed
to be on this is a
very different society so in terms of
like this new chapter in your life that
you're that you're kind of embarking on
how important is it to you to like
maintain these lifestyle habits of like
you know like we're like whether it's
you know restricting yourself in certain
we're like like you know yourself now
right so you don't you don't really have
to do all these things anymore but do
you still do them like you know when you
read Jesse's book it's like you're
sleeping in a chair you know you're
doing all this kind of stuff like I
don't imagine you're doing that now like
you feel like you have to how much do
you feel like you have to stay in touch
with that aspect of who you are I think
it's important to not go too far with it
but I always have to make sure that my
refrigerator is empty what that means is
yeah I'm successful now I've come to
Port in my life I'm very proud of myself
I love myself for all you people out
there who don't think it I'm very
peaceful
I love rebbe accomplished I'm so proud
of that but in the day the worst thing
that can happen to a man is he becomes
civilized
once she become so civilized that you
have everything you want that warrior
mentality I'm so proud of that I had to
it wasn't I wasn't born with it I had to
go through the crucible of my life to
acquire it you always want to keep that
thing sharp like a sword so you always
you don't have to sharpen it every day
that you did when you were going to
combat mm-hmm but if you leave it alone
for too long it gets a little dull and
that's my mind I always want to sharpen
out to do these things every single day
of my life but you always got to go back
and sharpen that sword every none and to
make sure that that mentality is still
there and your frigerator is still empty
because you're always going to keep that
edge and then as what keeps you going
forward right so if you had to if you
were put in a position to like be a high
school teacher and you could come up
with like any kind of curriculum huh you
want it for your students like what you
know what would that look like for you
the basis of my curriculum cuz education
is so important but 50 75 percent of it
would be yourself your mind mental
toughness up
to plan courage honor respect all these
things all these words this words people
use them as punchlines is I would get to
the core of these individuals and once
you get to the core of who you are then
we can succeed right everything else
will fall into place if you have that
right yet our educational system has
this massive blind spot right they don't
teach that we're not instilled with
these ideas and these are the ideas that
are either going to make you or break
you core values if you can light a spark
in someone if you can get them excited
about learning if you can get them
feeling good about who they are by
challenging them and getting them out of
their comfort zones right then you're
creating people that have a future
that's right and that will serve you
know all of us all right you better
write a lot better you know what I mean
right
so we got like a lot of work to do to
sort that out oh yeah oh I know a lot so
we're going to wrap this up in a little
bit so I can let you get back to your
life but one thing I thought might be
interesting to ask you you know there's
a lot of talk about kind of the role
that you played in changing Jesse it's
Lars life as a result of like living
with him but I'm interested in in what
that experience was like for you because
that's getting out of your comfort zone
to go like live with these people that
are living this crazy lifestyle who are
you know doing things that are
unfamiliar to you right like so what was
that like and what did you take away
from that for yourself you know I
they're super successful Sara Sara
Blakely Jesse Eclair Sarah Blake the
founder of Spanx these two individuals
are super super successful I took a lot
from it but one thing I took from it was
I'm very happy with my life with my life
of not having so much and you know they
have chefs and they have drivers and
they have so much stuff going on in
their life and I'm a SERP listicle I'm
very simplistic and my simplistic
lifestyle gave me the life I wanted I
was able to really I became even more
proud of Who I am and not in knowing
what I really want like you
look from the outside looking in like
man private jets and flying around and
man he I mean even I I mean all this
food and everything they want everything
is there once you go over there and you
live in that world it's great for some
people great for some people for me I
realize know what man that really is not
for me
Who I am the guy who has a backpack
right there that can go five days all
the stuff in the backpack have some
Subway sandwiches have a cookie every
now and then go on as little run come
back hit some push-ups pull-ups watch
the football game in some hole in the
wall or whatever and just be proud of
Who I am and not need anything else
external your son self is completely
divorced from your external
circumstances 100 per se and you know I
think Jesse's a happy dude very of that
guy he's Fanta
but it is interesting that even he you
know he sought out to go run ultras you
know it means like he was looking for
something more and he sought you out to
try to help him you know understand
certain things about how he could be
more fulfilled in the way that he's
living and and I credit him that's like
a most people wouldn't do that right you
know what I mean
exactly I regret it yeah he's a special
special guy in that but I think that
that's really cool yeah so let's wrap it
up with this I mean if there's one if
you can like to still you know
everything you're about into like kind
of one core message it you want people
to take away like what is it beyond what
we've already talked about like what is
it that's holding people back that's
limiting them that is you know that's
keeping them stuck in their blind spot
and how can you kind of speak to that to
perhaps you know shake it loose a little
bit and get people to think a little bit
differently about how to proactively
approach their lives the truth their
truth the real truth about who they are
as a person and I think it all really
starts there at the truth and knowing
that you may not be a courageous person
you may not have this and that but are
you willing to find it within yourself
to go
the very hard journey a lot of people in
this world have died 80 90 100 years old
and that the great life had a lot of
things but a lot of people who have died
never really started the true journey
that whatever you believe in God or
whatever you believe in if you'll even
nothing I believe we're all here to
start a journey and that journey is
[ __ ] hard if you choose your real
journey most of us we Sai take a
different journey in life it's a journey
of least resistance and so right
challenge people to do is to realize
that in themselves that yeah I have
taken a lot of left turns and I
shouldn't stay straight because why I
wasn't good at something and it
embarrassed me to not be good at
something or I wasn't the smartest
person on this or that whatever is all
these excuses we build up find the truth
of who you are go back to the start of
your journey and go down that path I
guarantee you if you finish that journey
and you don't fear and waver in go place
there very easy the other end of that
journey let me tell you it is a peaceful
end and I think it's over for me
but I believe the hardest part of my
life is over
I can't imagine anything else being
worse than this so yeah - welcome -
welcome the discomfort that comes with
that - like embrace the difficult aspect
where should we just want to run away
from all that stuff but that's like
because if you really want to connect
with who you are and you really want to
feel fulfilled right like you have to
confront that whether it's the lie that
you're telling yourself about who you
are or the secret that you're keeping or
you know that thing that you wish you
were doing but you're too afraid to
start doing it and that's the more of
the story man is um stop putting
categories on people and because you are
insecure yourself so it makes you feel
better as a person to say ah this guy
did this or this go to dad or whatever
it makes you feel that much better
people love seeing failure it makes them
feel so good about the
selves to see somebody not succeed at
something it makes them feel better next
hole Dorothea culture is built upon that
they love it man
they love it they love it good talking
to you dude you too my man yeah man
super this is going to rock people I'm
super excited to share this
I appreciate what you do and I wish you
well this new chapter in your life super
inspiring spend a little time with you
really it's an honor and privilege my
friend thanks for having me yeah thank
you so if you're digging on David like I
know you are best place to connect with
him is David Goggin comm and you're at
David Goggins on on Twitter and
Instagram but uh if you sling a little
nut Adam you might bite back haha yeah
we'll see
and anything else coming up or you're
doing a lot of public speaking these
days right now I'm speaking a lot yeah
like I said I did a 50-mile or two weeks
ago I'm giving myself a little break now
from that and I'm just doing my winter
routine was a lot of calisthenics is
still running always still running doing
a lot of bursar climber Jacob's Ladder
stuff like that switching it up a little
bit finding you know never staying in
the same pattern you know one of the
things Jesse said because I talked to
him before this I was like what should I
ask David that's not obvious you know
and he's like ask him about how he
stretches for four hours a day is that
true it is actually so I I had a multi I
have I still have a multitude of health
health issues right we didn't even you
know like I'm just being conscious of
the time but like we didn't we didn't
even talk about the fact that like in
2010 you know this crazy heart thing
right like I remember because you were
killing it in racing and then you just
had to stop right I wasn't he came back
in like 2013 but there was like a period
there where you were off the radar huge
period I was extremely sick I'm still
sick now so everything I talked about in
my life it comes to the price becomes a
huge price when you will yourself so we
don't have the ability and all you have
is will something's going to give and
what gives is your internal system so my
adrenals are shot so your genomes are
your fight-or-flight like I discussed I
was scared of everything I ever
in my life and I had to find something
much deeper than myself to pull out to
turn myself inside out and how I did it
was I used a lot of my adrenals and I
had to find this to get through all this
pain and suffering and fear and
basically my adrenals have shut down all
this they never I just said God is it
even worth it sure is people sure is
because that is my trophy not the
sickness I knew what I was doing to
myself when I was doing it I found what
I wanted to do but it
now I'm getting healthier but so I
stretched out because while the hip
flexors got so tight your psoas muscle
your psoas muscle is what tightens up
when you're in a fight or flight
situation
I was in a firefight situation all
through my deployments jumping out of
airplanes being in scary situations
doing things I hated doing was my whole
life pretty much that so has mostly got
so tight and started pulling on my 12
two laps my spine you have a bunch of
nerve endings going through there I can
go all day talking about this I got
severely very sick so basically what I
did was I started this crazy stretch
routine and I literally have healed
myself through the discipline I had and
what people won't believe is I got to a
point where I stressed out for 8 to 12
hours a day and then we also essentially
like most of your waking hours when
you're not working out stretching yeah
it went from that to 6 hours a day then
from 6 hours of data for is anymore it
opened up so the hips and what your zone
is there like a specific routine of
stretches that you would go through
where I was sitting stretches a whole
big routine a whole mess of like open up
your abductors because your ducts are
attached to your hips you hip flexors
your everything is a test at this region
here you're your midsection your your
hips and my hips get so tight that I
couldn't even squat down I had so much
back pain so that's why another reason
why I started running running you stay
upright
I could have squat anymore I couldn't do
any that powerlifting stuff so I just
only they can do is run running
embalming too bad you got to put my
curtain on either in my health got real
poor to my spine was collapse
and I've got real sick and basically I
healed myself because nobody no doctor
can find out what's wrong with me so I
couldn't run a lot I couldn't do any
activity so that's you know I'm gonna
bury myself in stretching and what
happens I had this huge knot on the back
of my head
the knot came from my spine collapsing
and getting tighter and tighter and
tighter it developed fluid or whatever
long story short as I started stretching
out that bump started going away and the
smaller the bump got the healthier I got
I was like what in the world is going on
so I was so I save every day so I would
feel this bump in the book and you can
see it right now yeah now I can see it
yeah mostly thinking about the bump the
back end my bump was like this big
mm-hmm it was huge
the more I stretched the more it would
away the more it would away the more the
healthier I got as I'm am so I'd be like
oh and keep on stretching so my
stretching became it was crazy
and I got healthier I was like my guy so
I stretched more and more and more and
now it's I've been doing now for three
years I haven't missed a day of session
in three years Wow so now is it is it
literally like is it are you still at
the for our market I'm now that like the
two-hour mark but what's funny about it
I went from so I want to raise cost
rolling Jim it's a 41 mile race in
Tennessee our average about seven minute
miles for 41 miles back in the back
country all them up and down hills I
could never even do that yeah I've run
marathons pretty fast but my average
training pace was an eight thirty eight
forty answer I stretched out my hitman I
was running pace now 7:15 and 7:30
and that's just because that's how crazy
tired I was so I'm a if I want to get
back in the ultra runner right now I
really compete at a high level for me I
would run racism in and a half faster
per mile that's crazy and that's what I
do now so I get strolling gym a few
years ago before I started stretching I
did it in five thirty something which is
a good time I did it this year this past
year in 450 Wow and you're probably not
training near the lonely you know no way
no way that's so interesting I mean
there's this whole other
camp surf philosophy especially in
running it's like anti stretching
they're out of their minds man strive
with the same way so I never stretched
the man anti because you could you you
lose those fibers those good
you're an idiot I would stretch out for
eight hours in a day
and yeah it takes a while for your body
get used to it but most of us are
sitting most the time when you said
you're tighten up that hip flexor muscle
that psoas muscle that's one of the most
important muscles in your strive to get
that long stride house first tricep
obstruct by inches mm-hmm
your stride is how you run if I start it
stretches like my god man I'm clipping
at 7:37 15 of the same harder strides
not were not restricted and I researched
as much as it was so I'm gaining a
minute per mile super in just by
stretches so people say [ __ ] because
they don't even know what the hell are
talking about they know so get knowledge
before you not read it I read I listen
to it so I didn't stretch it's a dumbest
thing of the planet and people suffer
don't hold a stretch lower than 30
seconds or a 15 whatever the hell [ __ ]
is I'll be in a stretch for 30 40
minutes come in it go out of it go in it
go out it go in it go out of it don't
believe everything you hear figure out
yourself yeah do your own research on
yourself like be your own guinea pig
right Express Mail so sit all right man
well I'll let you go all right yeah
maybe I can convince you to come back
and talk more this is really close
people won't hear any more I'm telling
you man double now keep are going to go
nuts this is great so thank you no
problem is having both peace
all right how did that one land for you
I got to tell you I really think that
this conversation is going to go down in
the annals of RRP history as one of the
most impactful if not the most impactful
most downloaded most popular podcasts
that I've ever done he was just amazing
and I really hope that you take this
message to heart I really hope that you
extract from this conversation the tools
and the resources and the inspiration to
reframe your own life trajectory to
raise the bar on the goals that you're
setting for yourself and I really look
forward to hearing from you guys
throughout the year on how these goals
are beginning to manifest in your life
so please reach out to me and let me
know how the progress is going as always
please make a point checking out the
show notes at rich roll com I got tons
of links and resources on the episode
page to help take your infotainment on
David and his work beyond the earbuds as
always thank you so much to everybody
for sharing the show with your friends
and on social media and around the water
cooler if you haven't done so already
please leave a review on iTunes that
helps us out a lot and while you're at
it click that subscribe button if you
haven't done that yet on iTunes or on
whatever podcast app or platform you use
to enjoy your podcast content as always
big love mad respect to everybody who
has made a practice of always using the
Amazon Dan rat on rich WorldCom for all
your Amazon purchases you can click
through to Amazon buy that banner at or
just type in rich WorldCom forward slash
Amazon buy whatever you're going to buy
doesn't cost you anything extra but
Amazon rewards us with a little
commission change and that really
supports the mission and for those of
you who have been gracious enough to
support my work beyond that on patreon I
want to thank you if you're inspired to
do that you can go to
patreon.com/scishow and thank you very
much if you guys want to hear from me by
email you can sign up for my weekly
email blast I send out a podcast class
at the beginning of the week letting you
know about this week's episode in
addition every Thursday I send something
out called roll call which is basically
a short free weekly sort of rundown of
tips tools resources basically things
that I've come across throughout the
week that are
fired me or that I found useful like
products documentaries books articles
and the like totally free I'm never
going to spam you you can sign up for
the newsletter on my website
we still have spots available for plant
power Australia February 20th through
27th we're taking 40 people through an
incredible seven-day life transforming
experience on the west coast of
Australia at Smith's Beach Resort it's
going to be amazing for more information
visit plant power worldcom and of course
go to rich roll comm for all your plant
power swag and merch needs I got signed
copies of our books finding ultra on the
plant power way we got t-shirts cool
stuff I want to thank today's sponsors
Harry's comm a superior shave on an
affordable price
friends of the ritual podcast can visit
Harry's com4 slash role to redeem your
free trial set which comes with a razor
five blade cartridge shaving gel and
post shave gel all you have to pay is
the shipping and me undies the world's
most comfortable underwear head to me
undies dot-com forward slash roll to get
free shipping in the US and Canada and
20% off your first pair I want to thank
Jason cami yellow for his work on audio
engineering and production on this
podcast Shawn Patterson for his help on
graphics Chris Swan for additional
production assistants as well as a lot
of help on the show notes and theme
music as always I am ulema thanks for
the love you guys it's been a great 2016
I'm super excited for 2017 again I
really hope that this episode helped
kick you into a new gear and how you
think and act and behave with respect to
yourself and the goals that you set for
yourselves heading into the next 12
months and I'll see you guys back here
next week peace plants
[Music]
you